thank you for joining us at six i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez we
have new videos showing the car involved
in that deadly north las vegas crash
just seconds before the collision 8 news
now's joe mohler joining us live with a
look at that video joe
well over the past year we've covered a
number of fatal crashes where speed
played a factor the latest one here at
cheyenne in commerce in north las vegas
it's a memorial continuing to grow
tonight earlier today we did speak with
a woman whose husband died just over a
year ago in a crash now she has a
message for others
100 miles per hour that is how fast
police say this maroon dodge challenger
was going before the deadly crash this
video is from maui one excavating on
commerce not even a block away from
cheyenne compare this car on the same
street you can see the difference in
speed it gets me really upset the crash
hits close to home for anne maria to
veria my husband was also killed in
december 2020. eric echeverria was
killed near fort apache and blue diamond
police say zion collins was driving 88
miles per hour also when a dodge
challenger before hitting his car at the
entrance to their neighborhood this is
really like damaged me and my family i'm
petrified to drive i will not drive at
night people just speed she says there
are too many crashes involving speed in
one year there has been at least
four that i know of four major major
accidents where people have died due to
speed
athletes and
dui she is talking about the crash
involving football player henry ruggs
that killed tina tintor and her dog and
the deadly crash involving andrew
rodriguez police say he was going 141
miles per hour in a lamborghini and now
this crash leaving nine dead as the
court process continues with zion
collins this sign calling for justice
still sits where her husband was killed
everybody you know that's been hurt by
this just has to they have no choice but
to go through
you know this horrible experience and
just something needs to be done
back out here live as this memorial
continues to grow the family tells us
the memorial is set up for this saturday
to remember the victims in this crash
and when it comes to this crash in the
investigation there's two investigations
one with the police department and now
the ntsb is investigating how speed
played a role reporting live in north
las vegas this evening joe muller live
local now